so you may never eat cereal again after
watching this video so this is a warning
just letting you know I mean everyone
knows that cereal is the healthy way to
start your day right we have all sorts
of wonderful healthy cereals out there
I mean they're a little fat they're zero
cholesterol loaded with heart healthy
fiber and their nutrient pack satisfying
your daily needs of at least eight
vitamins and minerals so today I'm going
to do a deep dive into cereal to see if
it really is as healthy as they promote
it to be okay now everything is based on
one serving size and of course they use
cups in America now for my friends in
Europe especially Dennis from Germany
this is the size of a cup now if I hold
it up here it looks huge but I put it
right to my head this is the size of a
cup right
it's about the same size as my coffee
cup this is the actual size of my coffee
mug right here so it's about the same
thing right so one cup equals 36 grams
of cereal now if I take a bowl and put
this cup into the bowl and you see the
cereal
there is no way that even a child is
going to consume only this much cereal
it's the most tiniest portion size right
so an average person or even an average
kid is going to consume at least four
servings of this cereal it's not going
to be this one cup so when I go through
some numbers we're going to have to
multiply it by four all right let's just
start off with the cereal we look at the
ingredients we have milled corn sugar
malt flavor with that one right here and
this one has whole grain wheat raisins
wheat bran sugar and then brown sugar
syrup now with Cheerios which is the
number one eaten cereal in America
the the second ingredient in Cheerios is
sugar and then corn starch and then
brown sugar syrup so there is a
tremendous amount of added sugar in
these cereals now I'm not even talking
about the real sugary cereals I'm just
talking about these two right here we're
talking about 17 grams of sugar per
serving size
so if we multiply that by four and that
comes down to 16 teaspoons of sugar now
we're not even talking about the
carbohydrates we're just talking about
the sugar alone 16 teaspoons okay now
let's talk about the total carbs one cup
is 47 grams if we times that by 4 we get
a 188 grams now what's going to happen
is that is going to spike your blood
sugar so your blood sugars are going to
go up and then what's going to happen is
insulin is going to have to be pumped
out
to bring those blood sugars down so
you're going to be really hungry and
tired about an hour and a half to two
hours later when you end up with low
blood sugars you're going to need a
snack or you're going to be just
ravenously hungry at lunchtime now that
amount of carbohydrate and sugar is not
even at the top of the list with some of
the cereals out there some of the soils
out there are at least 50 percent or
more sugar okay by weight and so in
other words what a lot of people are
consuming is just a tremendous amount of
sugar in the morning the worst time you
can eat sugar which I will get into
shortly so one of the most sensitive
areas of your body that's affected me
sugar is your brain your brain does not
store Sugar it's dependent on what's
going on in the blood so if you're
constantly flooding the brain when sugar
what's going to happen is you're going
to create an insulin resistance it's
like a protective mechanism where over
time you're going to be more resistant
to that insulin problem and so now now
the brain cells are going to have a
harder harder time getting that glucose
because you built up this resistance
this protective mechanism and so what
happens your brain cells just don't get
fuel and they start to malfunction and
this is where you have a loss of
cognitive function your concentration
goes down your memory goes down your
focus goes down you become very
distracted easily it's called add and
this especially applies if
the person consuming this cereal is a
student they're they're going to have a
heck of a time in school of course I
went through this I had lived on cereal
all the way up until I think I was maybe
28 years old and I just hit 32 so you
know I've been off sugar for you know a
few years so all of this extra blood
sugar and carbs is going to start
working on developing a fatty liver
uh making fat around the organs in your
midsection uh creating a diabetic State
creating inflammation creating a high
cholesterol situation even though
there's no cholesterol in this cereal
your body converts the carbs into
cholesterol it affects the cognitive
function like I mentioned it affects
your mood bringing you into an anxiety
state and of course it also affects your
teeth you know it causes cavities and
even your heart and somehow they're able
to associate the fiber to this heart
healthy little thing right here so
people annoyingly are going to consume
that thinking is going to help their
heart because there's an association
with lowering fiber and lowering
cholesterol and even though it's been
completely debunked having low
cholesterol is not the thing that's
going to actually save your heart now
the next one I want to talk about is the
actual fiber how much fiber are in these
cereals well in one serving it's just
one gram to me that's not high fiber one
gram of fiber now maybe I'm missing
something but
I'm looking at this as a low fiber
so-called food this is not high fiber so
maybe someone in the discussion down
below can educate me on on the fiber in
this cereal but I'm just reading and it
says one gram of fiber okay so we have
this massive carb mass of sugar tiny bit
of fiber I'm trying to understand how
that's going to help your heart you see
there's two things that help buffer this
blood sugar insulin thing okay one is
fat which this has virtually zero and
the other one is fiber which we're only
talking about a really tiny bit of fiber
so there's really no buffer to this
blood sugar so the blood sugar goes up
and it goes up fast so now the next
thing I want to get into is this whole
grain versus refined grain because at
least the Raisin Bran has the whole
grain okay this one just is milled corn
all right that's refined but whole grain
okay what's so healthy about whole grain
well it's nutritious right it has all
these vitamins and minerals and it has
the fiber and has the complete package
but it also has phytic acid and if
you're not familiar with phytic acid
it's a very potent binder to key
nutrients like iron like zinc like
magnesium like manganese like calcium
like copper so the phytic acid in the
whole grains binds these nutrients
making them unavailable to you now there
are millions and millions of people and
even kids that are deficient in zinc and
I really believe it's due to the cereal
because in certain countries people are
eating a lot of cereal and they don't
eat a lot of animal meat they don't eat
red meat things like that which is
loaded with bioavailable zinc they're
also like an iron deficient anemia is
also very common with kids and pregnant
women and a good percent of the
population function so what happens with
an iron deficiency is you're not able to
carry the oxygen like you should in the
blood and also the number of red blood
cells go down and a really good way to
identify an iron deficiency well there's
several but one good way is to look
inside your eyelid and see if it's red
or pale okay because if you're iron
anemic it will be pale at least 50 of
the time not 100 of the time and also
the person will crave ice they'll just
like to chew on ice and they have dark
circles underneath their eye and their
nails are spooned up so that's iron
magnesium deficiencies will show up as
leg cramps fatigue
uh difficulty sleeping anxiety Calcium
deficiency can show up as many different
ways it can show up as cramps as well
because it's an electrolyte it can also
show up as bone loss now what about the
refined grains right because with
refined grains you have less phytic acid
right well here's the problem with
refined grains you're going to deplete
these same nutrients in a different way
when you consume a lot of refined grains
and or refined sugar you deplete
potassium calcium zinc and magnesium
from the body so whether using phylic
acid to deplete these nutrients or
you're using just refined grains you're
still going to end up with a deficiency
and so now how can they say that cereal
is so nutrient dense and that's because
any and all nutrients in that cereal is
added to this cereal as an enhancement
or a fortification and so if you look at
the label it'll have calcium carbonate
added ferric phosphate which is a type
of iron that you don't want to put in
your body it has palmitate which is a
synthetic vitamin A and sodium ascorbate
which is synthetic vitamin C and on top
of all that
when they process these grains they heat
them under high pressure and not only
does that kill off any natural vitamins
it's going to kill off the synthetic as
well but the fact that they put these
synthetic vitamins in there they can
make a claim that it has nutrients in it
and then I won't even get into the
artificial coloring the artificial
flavoring and other chemicals like BHT
and BHA which can affect your endocrine
system their carcinogens and there's a
certain loophole that allows them to put
them in these cereals so I would highly
recommend if you're going to do
breakfast at all and especially your
kids I would start doing eggs eggs as
your base okay do eggs and bacon eggs
and avocado eggs and sausage or other
types of protein like a burger patty
with tomatoes something like that but if
you start your day with cereal you're
going to end up with a roller coaster
ride of blood sugars up and down to the
whole day to the point where at night
you're going to crave sugar like crazy
and you're going to want to graze for
the Raw type of food and like I said
before I have a lot of personal
experience on this topic because of the
years and the amount of sugary cereal
that I consumed now this whole cereal
started with John Harvey Kellogg now he
was an MD and nutritionist he promoted
vegetarianism he was the guy that really
started the trend on soy milk granola
meat substitutes he was also into some
other weird stuff called Eugenics so
Eugenics is a belief in practice
involving improving the genetic quality
of humans so the goal is to eliminate
inferior genetics there's some people
that practice Force sterilization of
those unfit for reproduction even
filtering up people with lower IQ and
Kellogg was the co-founder of this
organization called the race betterment
foundation so apparently this whole
practice of eugenics has died out thank
goodness but it sounds pretty crazy to
me I mean the best way to support your
genes is to have a healthy lifestyle and
to eat good especially when someone is
pregnant so here Kellogg's was promoting
the cereal for these kids when in fact
that's creating nutritional deficiencies
that's affecting IQ because if you're
eating Ultra processed foods you're
going to create all sorts of problems
like iodine deficiencies which directly
relate to a lowered IQ so here he was
trying to strengthen the genetics when
in fact he was weakening the genetics
all right sensor on the topic of foods
that don't make you healthy if you have
not seen the most dangerous food that
you can eat I put that video up right
here check it out